our next roaster is here representing
her husband something she's getting
pretty tired of doing already her last
appearance was on the news see show CBS
13 minutes this is an extraordinary lady
that we're all going to get to know
better and better I think when she
replaces her husband on the ticket gets
Ron Brown out and Gloria Steinem in as
chairman of the party and we roll on to
a new America this is an extraordinary
lady we are kidding aside we have all
come to know and appreciate her a great
deal representing her husband from the
great state of Arkansas Hillary Clinton
right air
thank you well I have the answer to
Larry's question it's ten o'clock and
where is Bill Clinton Bill Clinton Larry
and I've come to Washington to make just
a complete confession it's hard but you
know there just comes a time when you
have to stand up there and say it like
it is Bill Clinton is with the other
woman in his life and i'm sure you'll
read about it as you're checking out of
the supermarket next week and when you
do I want you to know that you heard it
first here that he is back in little
rock arkansas which has become the
capital of all kinds of stories
attending a why teen dance with his
daughter Chelsea
you know after the week I've had I don't
want to roast anybody
I did not really understand what bill
meant a couple of months ago when we got
into this presidential campaign and he
looked at me one day and he said you
know my big problem in this campaign is
I have to figure out how to escape
obscurity well he figured out how to
escape obscurity and it has been an
exciting a couple of days for us and
Paul there is a very simple answer to
your question about how to get on the
Larry King show you or Nicky just have
to figure out how to get into the
supermarket tabloids ever since this
happened my phone has been ringing off
the hook with people representing Larry
King asking if I would be on the show
and they handed me the note and I said
who's Larry King
now that I know the answer is still no
Larry I am sorry that two of the other
candidates couldn't be here I'm sorry
that my husband couldn't be here these
events are you know just kind of command
performances for people in their
positions who have to show up and you
know they have to take time out of their
campaigning and they have to round up
their friends to try to give them some
funny lines and it's always so hard to
know what you're going to say and it's
hard to capture the mood and you just
never quite know what is going to happen
in an event like this the one thing
though that I am really grateful for is
the breakthrough that Paul Tsongas has
achieved in obliterating the distinction
between the genders in political life in
America now you may not have seen this
unless you watch c-span or you've been
in New Hampshire of Massachusetts but
Paul is running a courageous ad with him
in that speedo swimsuit that somebody
referred to earlier and it really is a
terrific at and he does look great and I
think it sets a new standard for what we
can expect of political candidates
because remember it is women who have
walked up and down the aisle in the
closest we've ever got to be the
president united states and the Miss
America contest year after year and
everybody watches it and says oh we're
really interested in her talent and you
know that everybody moves up close to
the TV set when the swimsuit competition
goes on and so what Paul has done for us
is to make it very clear that we're
going to judge people exactly the same
and remember when you vote for president
you want to see them in the speedo
swimsuit and poise and talent only count
for forty percent
i also have heard and I've heard so many
rumors this week I can't even keep track
of them some of them are just
extraordinary and I bet you've heard a
lot of them too and I bet some of you
have started some of them but that's
okay with me I don't mind the one that I
liked the best though had to do with my
old friend Jerry Brown and this is a
really tough rumor to deal with but I
wish Gary were here because I know he'd
have a quick answer there is a rumor
that Jerry did have a date in the 1980s
there are investigative reporters
looking everywhere and they may come and
ask you if you have any leads we're also
pleased to see tom harkin here you know
Tom and Bill have a lot in common they
both have wives who support them in
these efforts that they are engaged in
both emotionally and financially i might
add but you know i have always believed
in this country and no sacrifice is too
great so I know Ruth feels the same way
and you guys just go on out there and do
what you're doing and make us proud
the real reason though we're here is to
roast somebody who frankly has been
roasted for four years meet Ron Brown
was out there on his own month after
month year after year when everybody
thought the Democratic Party was dead he
could hardly get on the Larry King show
or any other show he was beating that
drum and saying yes we can come back we
can make it he had hardly any name
recognition until the Gulf War you all
don't realize but the Gulf War made Ron
Brown and that's because everybody
including including Norman Schwarzkopf
thought he was Prince Bandar of Saudi
Arabia
I mean I mean think of a look at Ron and
then the next time you see prince bandar
look at the prince I'm not sure that
they aren't one in the same they both
are impeccably tailored they speak
diplomatically and they spend a lot of
money and they just absolutely come from
the same cloth of accomplished people
but you know when he was out there all
by himself there were a lot of people
who just almost cringed when they saw
Ron comin because they knew he was going
to give them a pep talk and he was going
to try to engage them in believing as he
did that this country would not continue
to follow the failed policies of Reagan
and Bush and that someday we would all
wake up from this dream like trance that
we had been put into and I think that
not just Democrats but Americans Oh Ron
Brown a big debt of thanks
I don't think even Ron could have
predicted that President Bush would so
clearly exemplify what he had been
saying for months and years that the
Republicans just don't get it because
anyone who watched that state of the
union address Tuesday night knew exactly
what Ron Brown had been saying for all
those years that eventually the string
would run out their luck would give and
we would have an opportunity but the
other side of Ron's message and really
why I think that he's been a leader for
all times and one of the greatest if not
the greatest chairman and tough times
the Democrats have ever had is that he
never gave up hope in this presidential
campaign if it is about anything is
about hope and as I've traveled around
the country and I've been so many places
now and just came back from three days
in South Dakota and Colorado people want
to believe again they want to believe in
their country they want to believe they
can take it back and they want to
believe we can do something with it if
they vote for us and I believe that much
of the predicate for that belief was
laid in those early lonely years by Ron
Brown and on behalf I think not just of
my husband Ron but all of the Democrats
running and all of the Democrats for
whom you have given hope we want to
thank you very much for staying with us
and showing us the way
von Braun